the Joe Rogan experience and the reality
the 55s is like that's a [ __ ]
horrible strain for your body right
right no I remember I you know seeing
guys cut weight and be in a lot of
trouble physically right yeah but our
thing was always make weight no matter
what I mean that's just the way it was I
think I had one guy that didn't make
weight for a fight in the IFL and he got
run out of the gym because of it right
right he just got run out of the gym
because everybody was so pissed at him
for not making weight right I'm seeing
some horrible weight cuts with people
but I had a weight cut where it was in
New Jersey the weigh-ins were the day of
the fight which fight was this Joanie
Carter at Continental Airlines our bands
for the day of the fight that morning
right why just the way it was and the
way it broke down the way it all went
down was I had a new gym a Gold's Gym
building a brand-new house had a brand
new baby and I had to win the fight to
have enough money for the down payment
on the house oh Jesus they're already
building it we already signed the
paperwork oh Christ
so I'm cutting weight and I've been so
busy that I wasn't paying enough
attention to my weight and I was
struggling so the whole night I stayed
awake the whole night and all I thought
about was I know I can beat this guy's
not gonna beat me but if he had buts me
or for whatever reason and I don't win
the fight and I lose that money I lose
my house oh my god I start to panic
right and when you're cutting weight
like that it's everything's magnified
100 times the mat just the fear and
everything else and all I thought about
was that water and egg white or
scrambled eggs all night the whole night
and by the time it was time to weigh in
I went and knocked on Matt Hughes and
James Palmer's door and I go hey man I'm
in serious trouble right now
I'm I because I sucked on ice cubes all
night and I gained like two pounds or
whatever so I had to go cut again what
I've sewn weight just from sucking on
ice cubes semi two pounds of ice cube I
guess yeah cuz I didn't even know where
I was that I was losing my mind
Wow so I did that all night and then so
I made weight and then I went back to my
hotel room and I started cramping
everything cramped I had the time I
wrestling shoes on as tight as I could
possibly time so my feet wouldn't Bend
like this whoa and then my calves
started cramp and everything cramped to
the point where I was curled up in the
fetal position and I knew I had to fight
that night holy [ __ ] so I couldn't see
right there was a bunch of stuff go
along with my body so I called up Monty
Cox in his room and I go you got to get
somebody to take me to the hospital to
get IVs or this shit's not happening he
goes all right I'm sending Tom shower
right so you remember Tom salads so
Tom's Howard comes to get me and
everybody who knows Tom knows he had
really severe Tourette's right really
severe Tourette's like if he's around
black people the n-words getting yelled
constantly right he's around women he's
yelling hunt or [ __ ] the whole time
he's really loud so anyway he comes
against me takes me to the hospital
we're walking up to the hospital in New
Jersey the whole Hospital is all glass
windows everybody that works in the
hospital is black oh no now imagine the
kind of situation I'm in mentally and
physically and I stop and I put my hand
on his chest and I go Tom you cannot go
in here with me oh my god you're gonna
yell the n-word a million times they're
gonna kick us out I'm not gonna get my
IVs right I'm not gonna be able to fight
I'm gonna lose my house losing my mind
right and he goes Pat it's okay chirp
chirp lick lick right he goes it's fine
he goes I'm a Dade County paramedic he
goes I deal with this constantly it's
okay so we walk in we go up to the nurse
at the reception desk and he goes hey he
goes my friend click-click-click n-word
n-word n-word she looks at him and goes
say what and he goes I have Tourette's I
have severe Tourette's please don't he
goes my friend needs an IV badly and she
looks at me and goes oh [ __ ] like I
looked that bad my eyes were way back in
my head I was in rough shape so they
gave me three liters of saline
three liters yeah revived me and I feel
like a two-liter Pepsi that one three of
those about three three two one liters
yeah there's a lot of water right right
and so they revived me enough I was
still seeing double when it came fight
time and so the first round I just took
Shoni down I threw him took him down
stayed mounted on him the whole first
round to get him to wear himself out
right just hit him with punches elbows
just stuff just not going overboard but
I wanted him to be tired going into the
second round
how diminished are you in this state bad
yeah it was bad like half half your
company maybe yeah
so the second round I just went okay now
I gotta end it so I just I had kicked
him and knock him out I remember that
and I just went I made it out of that
with the skin of my teeth food you know
but so just weight cutting can be very
extreme yeah I really can but we always
believed in you have to make weight then
you sign your name and that's why I get
so pissed off and disgusted when people
don't make way yeah well it's a lack of
discipline it for sure if unless it's
not physically possible for you to make
the weight like if you're a heavy weight
you want to make light weight that's not
physically possible right so then don't
sign it's a lack of commitment see
that's the thing that I I'm disgusted
most with is that people don't aren't
committed to what they do right
you've obviously committed to what you
do you're very good at the things that
you do right it is it's obvious you're
obviously a talented guy but you work at
your craft right you know there came a
time where I had to leave college just
go home take care of my alien mother and
had to work three jobs and realized
sitting in the basement that I was
raised in every time it rained it
flooded my feet were in water I woke up
one morning and I was doing you know had
started out fighting and everything and
I said this is it I'm gonna win a world
title I'm gonna win a UFC title what's
it this is it and I loaded a
nine-millimeter pistol and I put a round
in the chamber and I put it in my sock
drawer and I said if I don't want a
world title that guns going in my mouth
and I'm done
this is it right so every time I fought
I thought about that gun in my sock
drawer and not wanting to go home to it
and that's just that's commitment
that was my that's what was needed for
me to succeed at that point in my life
that's the way it was so when I see
people not when they're talented and
they're not committed I don't want
anything to do with them I just don't I
don't have time for people like that
I'll take a guy who's committed and
sucks and train him every day
because I love his commitment
[Applause]